great thanks very much excited to see
how the day unfolds here looks like a
great great program so for most animals
movements are sensory information is
acquired in the context of movements or
an exploration so think of active touch
exploring a surface with your fingers or
a rat or a mouse exploring with his
whiskers think of eye movements and
vision or movements of the head and the
ears in hearing so in all of these cases
movements allow animals to acquire more
and better information about the world
but they also pose a fundamental
challenge for sensory systems so sensory
systems in the brain have to distinguish
between patterns of receptor activation
due to external behavior the relevant
events so stimulus out in the world from
patterns of receptor activation that may
be similar or identical that are a
direct consequence of the animals own
behavior and movements and these are
classically termed react breasts and a
classical solution to this so-called
problem of reference is that sensory
centers in the brain in addition to
receiving this ambiguous sensory input
could also receive additional
information in the form of copies of
motor commands these have been called
efference copy i'll refer to them today
as corollary discharges so the idea is
that sensory regions could use this
corollary discharge to generate a model
that predicts the set of three
consequences of motor commands and these
ideas were formulated first by sperry
von holston middle stat in the 50s and
i'll read you this quote quickly so we
shall propose that the e friends this is
motor output leaves an image of itself
somewhere in the cns to which the
reactance of this movement compares is
the negative of a photograph compares to
its print so that when superimposed the
image disappears so this is an early
formulation of the idea of a forward
model or a prediction of the sensory
consequences of a motor command and this
is going to be my entry point in turn to
our models today and it turns out that a
really good place to study this kind of
model is
this unusual creature that is a focus of
research in my lab this weekly electric
fish from Africa so for the rest of the
talk will dive into the unusual sensory
motor systems in this fish I'll try to
give you a detailed mechanistic picture
of how kind of simple internal model is
generated in the brain of this of this
creature so these electric fish have
receptors scattered over their skin that
are sensitive to weak electrical fields
for example fields emitted by other
animals in the water like a bug that
this fish might want to eat these are
called passive laughter receptors this
fish is special because he also has an
electric organs a modified muscle in his
tail that emits a weak electrical field
and he uses this to communicate with
other fish it's actively electro locate
via second class of electro receptors
that I'll talk about a little bit at the
end of the talk but in the beginning
we're going to be focused on the plight
of the passive electrosensory system and
from the perspective of this system the
fish's large electric organ discharge
pulse is a severe sources all generated
noise so this is a histogram of the
spiking response of one of these passive
electro receptors and after each
electric organ discharge or EOD pulse
this receptor sent into this ringing
pattern of activation and this is a
problem particular problem for a couple
of reasons this perturbation of the
receptor response is long-lasting in
time so it lasts around 200 milliseconds
which is about the same duration as they
are same interval as the fish is pulsing
so if you simply gated this interference
out there'd be no time left to sense the
world so that solution is not going to
work another problem is that this
interference pattern is not fixed but it
changes depending on the environment on
multiple time scales and in this example
we see that changes in water
conductivity have a large effect on how
this electric organ discharge will
affect these electro receptors so the
fish may need to learn the sensory
electric organ discharge and what I'll
tell you now our understanding of how
this learning actually occurs and
fortunately from being a lot is the very
first stage of electro sensory
processing in a central brain structure
called the electrosensory lobe so all4
short and the two major inputs to e ll
our sensory input from receptors on the
skin that I've talked about and then
also a corollary discharge or a copy of
the motor command that discharges the
electric organ so the motor command
nucleus sends command down the spinal
cord to the electric organ and the tail
and then a copy up into e ll and so
through lots of study of this structure
we know a lot at the cellular and
circuit level as well so a main site of
integration of the electro sensory input
and the corollary discharge input are
these cell types here the medium
ganglion cells that I'll talk about at
length today and these cells are
interesting because they receive their
corollary discharge input via mossy
fiber granule cell parallel fiber system
that closely resembles to the circuitry
of the cerebellum so we referred to the
e ll as a cerebellum like sensory
structure so you believe some of the
insights and we'll come back to this
some of the insights from a allow may be
relevant to understanding how internal
so I'm going to summarize now about
three decades worth of work on our
understanding of how this process of
negative image formation forward models
happens in the structure of e ll and
this is largely work of Curtis Bell and
his colleagues so remember the problem
is that after each EOD command there's
this ringing pattern of activation that
the system should cancel out if it wants
to perceive events in the world so the
problem reduces to forming a temporally
specific negative image and if the
system could do that perfectly if it
could create an opposite temporal
pattern and subtract that from the
incoming effect of the EOD then the
output of these mg cells would be flat
and they would be sensitive they'd be
poised to detect unexpected behaviorally
relevant events in the world
and so do we actually have any evidence
this happens of course we do is while
you're studying is strange fish is that
you can actually record these negative
images from these mg cells in vivo and
see the formation of these negative
images in real time okay so you can
record from the cell initially the
effects of the corollary discharge are
minimal so this is a spike raster
triggered on the time of the EOD command
in a paralyzed fish in which the EOD the
omission of the EOD is blocked if you
add a mimic of the fish's EOD which is
shown by the line here you can strongly
drive active activity in the cell a
pause and that an excitation that
pattern diminishes over time and then
when you turn the stimulus off so when
you again look at just the effects of
the corollary discharge alone you see
will appear on opposite path and this is
what we refer to as the negative image
so the point is that you can actually
study these negative images and observe
your works and real-time system the
first insight into the cellular
mechanisms came from slice studies that
showed that the synapses conveying the
corollary discharge information to the
mg selves are plastic so they're
modified by recent activity and the form
of this plasticity was particular in
particularly interesting was an anti
hebbian form of spike timing dependent
plasticity so in this kind of plasticity
rule pre synaptic inputs that come
before or predict a postsynaptic spike
or weakened inputs coming in at
different delays or strengthen so this
kind of anti hebbian rule is perfect for
removing correlations between pre and
post synaptic activity and intriguingly
it was just the kind of learning rule
that you would need to generate a
negative image so this is this is the
learning rule
so the next important piece of the
puzzle was collaboration with Patrick
Robertson who did some elegant modeling
work that showed if in addition to this
learning rule you had an explicit
representation of time in the granule
cells and this schematic he thought
about it in terms of a delay line
representation so with this
representation of time in this learning
rule you could account for the formation
of these temporary specific negative
images that were observed okay so this
is basic model of how this process of
negative images could work and this is
where today and our work comes in is to
fill in this missing piece of the puzzle
here so the delay line representation
was a hypothetical idea we didn't know
how corollary discharges are actually
represented and transformed in the
granule cell so like the cerebellum the
granule cells and this electric fish are
tiny neurons it's not trivial to monitor
their activity so this would remain kind
of a mystery until recently and it's
important here because the EOD command
itself so the copy the literal copy of
the motor command is just a brief pulse
so just a couple spikes very brief and
restricted in time so a copy of the
motor command itself in a suitable
language it's not a representation of
time so the question here an important
general question about this kind of
internal model is how do you go from a
copy of a motor command into a
prediction of a sensory consequence the
two things are in quite different
languages so this is part of the the
mystery that we're going to try to to
address today at the circuit level okay
so our approach to this was
straightforward if somewhat tedious one
so what we wanted to do is to look at
the activity the corollary discharge
representations in the granular layer
cell by cell and the key cells are the
granule cells themselves which are the
cells that give rise to the parallel
fibers that send input to the mg cells
and the cerebellum this would be a
purkinje cell and in addition the key
elements that provide the info to the
granule
sells these are the mossy fibers these
provide excitatory input to the granule
cells these are the inputs that are
conveying the copy of the motor command
from the motor centers and then in
addition to important classes of
interneurons the only interneurons in
the granular layer both in mammals and
an electric fish inhibitory golgi cells
and then unipolar brush cells which are
excitatory inter neurons that give rise
to intrinsic mossy fibers system that
also provide excitation to the granule
cells so we wanted to look at the
corollary discharge representations in
these classes of neurons so we did this
in a preparation a paralyzed fish in
which the electric organ discharge
itself is blocked but the fish is awake
and he continues to spontaneously emit
the motor command to discharge the
electric organ you can measure this
motor command with a electrode near the
tail and so we have a fictive
preparation which it's straightforward
for us to look at corollary discharge
because there is no sensory consequence
of the motor command in this prep so
it's a good prep to look at corollary
discharge response which is anything
locked to the fish's motor okay so what
do we see so first when we saw when we
recorded from the mossy fibers the
inputs from the motor command centers we
saw as expected that the responses and
these are spike histograms here on the
Left examples and then here's summary of
all the cells we recorded in the form of
color plot so each row is a cell and so
as expected we saw the external inputs
were restricted in time so it puts been
a Motor Club command centers indeed
resemble literal copies of the motor
commands their responses were highly
stereotyped and interestingly as we
recorded inside inside of the granular
layer which we call EG p so when we
recorded inside of this granular layer
we found these kind of responses these
early responses but in addition we saw
responses that were more temporal a
diverse and delayed and so we have some
examples of these responses here is a
cell that is bursting later in the
command cycle a cells that fire
tonically pause and then fire this
ringing
of activation after the command so these
seem to be potentially raw material for
the temporary specific negative images
that we know the fish can form and one
of the first findings that we made using
a combination of extracellular and
intracellular recordings was it the
source of these diverse and delayed
temporal responses were collapse of
inter neuron called the unipolar rush
sounds this was unexpected but
interesting for us that the temporal
didn't be coming from these cells
intrinsic to the granular layer some
theories of cerebellum hypothesized the
Golgi cells might play this kind of a
role and in our system we saw golgi cell
responses were mainly temporarily
restricted so the first finding is that
there is temporal diversity in the
granular layer it may be generated by
these unipolar brush cells and we got a
little bit of additional insight into
this from some of our intracellular
recordings from these unipolar brush
cells and some of these cells we find
that hyperpolarizing the salvia current
injection caused a large burst of spikes
when the hyperpolarization was
terminated and if we looked at the same
responses of these same cells to the EOD
motor command we saw that sells fired
largest bursts when they were most
hyperpolarized so suggestive again of a
rebound from inhibition kind of
mechanism so the point of all this is
just that the intrinsic synaptic
properties of these unipolar brush cells
may demselves be sufficient for
generating temporal diversity in the
granular layer and people that look at
these cells and mammals in in vitro work
have come to similar conclusions of
these cells have quite interesting
synaptic and intrinsic properties so it
may be a shoo-in for myself I'm a
dedicated channel for injecting temporal
diversity into the granular layer so the
important output of the granular layer
are of course the granule cells
themselves so we next turned our
attention to what's happening in these
cells here I've selected a few traces
these are the average membrane
potentials of granule cells locked to
the EOD motor man and we see a few
things we see responses that are quite
early that resemble the responses of the
mossy fibers coming from the motor
command center but in
addition we see other patterns of
activation that are more diverse and
delayed so here we see a cell that seems
to be paused hyperpolarized early and
shows this oscillating pattern of
activity that's reminiscent of some of
the mossy fiber in the unipolar brush
cell inputs that I showed you a minute
ago other cells that are most active
late so this is interesting if we look
at a hole at the granule cells hundred
granule cells total that we recorded we
see these same features but also
something important and additional and
that is that the large majority of the
granule cells are active only on a very
short delay so we see kind of a mixed
picture here on the one hand we have
some temporal diversity in the responses
so some activity late that could
contribute to temporally specific
negative images delayed responses but
also majority of cells whose activation
is restricted to early delay so this is
not a delay line representation that was
predicted by or was used in early
modeling work that we know could explain
negative images but quite a different
type of representation so the question
that and for us becomes one of asking is
this representation that we now have
observed suitable for generating
negative images via the learning rule
that we've measured so the key
ingredients key ingredients are known a
temporal basis a learning rule and we
want to know now can we explain these
negative images so we know with a delay
line that we could account for these but
can we extend parole basis of suitable
one so for this question and we had a
couple choices one of the challenges is
that we're whereas we recorded 200
granule cells one g cell receives 20,000
granule cell in putzes and this is
similar to the massive convergence of
granule cells onto purkinje cells in
cerebellum so there's a gap between the
data we can record in the raw material
for the negative images in the actual
system so we had two choices one was to
return to the lab and record for the
remaining eighteen thousand or so
granule cells another choice was to turn
to a different
not about that and went across the
street and talked to Larry Abbott and
some of his bright students in the
center for theoretical neuroscience and
Kennedy Patrick and Greg and we thought
we could come up with a plan together of
how to bridge this explanatory gap
between these pieces of the puzzle that
we could measure and the output of the
system the negative images that we want
to understand so we were aided in this
pursuit by the fact that the granule
cells and these are the first the first
cells that we're going to try to
understand using the model modeling
approach or very simple cells each
granule cell just gets a handful of
excitatory inputs to 24 on these
claw-like dendrites so this is where the
excitatory mossy fiber or excited to our
unipolar brush cell input synapses and
so interestingly what we found was that
it looked at the responses from the
granule cells that we measured so this
is the member measured membrane
potential response and then we carefully
selected using sparse regression
techniques an appropriate one two or
three recorded mossy fiber or ubc inputs
that we could account for the response
simply by some mating excitatory inputs
so here is a model fit in green it was
achieved just by appropriately selecting
and summing to recorded moscow fiber ru
bcn puts this is an early mossy fiber
from extrinsic source this is one of the
cute achieve unipolar brush cells within
EGP we add those two ends together as
they're added in the actress L can
account for the response so we could do
this for all of the granule cells are
you recorded from here's a sample of the
actual responses in blue is in green and
the assignment for the selected mossy
fiber or ubc inputs one two or three
that explain that response so there's
two values to this exercise one is that
we have a better understanding of how
the temporal responses in these granule
cells actually arise so this is an
important question also in the
cerebellum the cerebellum most of the
three quarters of the neurons in your
brain of the cerebellar granule cells we
know very little bit about the
transformations that are performed in
the grand
layer and what these granule cells
actually represents so here we have a
picture of how inputs to the granular
layer corollary discharge inputs are
transformed into postsynaptic granule
cell responses we have these simple
rules and then more germane to our goal
our immediate goal here of explaining
negative images is that this model gave
us a tool that allowed us to bridge this
gap between the two hundred granule
cells we could record in the twenty
thousand granule cells that form a basis
for negative images and so we did this
by inverting the model and so now
understand these rules vision mossy
fibers and ubc inputs generate granule
cell responses we could now construct
our own granule cells and so we're using
recorded mossy fiber and UBC data mix
together in a fashion consistent with
the this fitting procedure that we saw
work so well and we can construct
artificial granule cell so here's to
recorded inputs selected some together
here's the response of a model granule
cell this one happens to spike kind of
at a medium delay demands of course we
wanted to check check synthetic
constructed cells against the recorded
cells here's a selection of around 200
out of 20,000 of these generated granule
cells compared to the actual cells
responses that we measured again this is
a membrane potential of the cell after
the time after the motor command on the
x-axis here you see there's a pretty
good resemblance between the recorded
cells and these selected is 25 this
selection of the 20,000 was made
randomly so we didn't pick this to look
like the actual cells so with this in
hand we have a good tool now to probe
the question that we sought out to to
look at initially can this basis account
for negative images together with the
learning rule so now if we plug in our
20,000 granule cells pass them through
plastic synapses we can at least in a
model have a more direct approach to
this question and that's what we did
this is work of ann kennedy so i'm
showing you now the output of a model mg
cell
twenty thousand granule cell inputs the
strength of these inputs is adjusted
according to the measured aunty habian
synaptic plasticity rule we can see the
first time point here in the model we
introduce an input to the model that
represents the self generated effects of
the electric organ discharge so the in
the color scheme here you see what is
the ringing pattern of activation that's
due to the effects of the EOD on the
receptors and then over the course a few
hundred trials so this is a similar time
scale to that in which we see negative
image is forming in vivo you see that
the effects of the EOD diminish and go
away so the system is this model on the
model we see the expected cancellation
of the sensory consequences of the EOD
if we turn the effects if we turn the
EOD off what we see underneath is a
temporally specific negative image so
that's the dashed blue line here it's
opposite of the effect of the sensory
input on the mg cell and this is exactly
what we see in vivo so to first pass we
think that even though this temporal
basis is not a little delay line it does
seem to be able to explain negative
images that we see in people so this is
encouraging we can take them out a
little bit further to gain some insight
into why this temporal basis that we
recorded this pattern of granule cell
activation works as well as it does so
to address this question and asked about
the quality and the rate of the sensory
cancellation for inputs that resemble
the effects of the EOD on electro
receptors so this black line here so in
the real system the EOD pulse comes in
shortly after the motor command the
largest effect has at a short delay and
then there's this ringing pattern so the
effect diminishes over time so she
compared the effects of this pattern the
ability of the system to cancel this
pattern with the ability of the system
to cancel artificial signals that were
matched to their power spectrum but
shifted in phase so in blue we see a
family of artificial signals that the
fish would not ever encounter in nature
but we're similar in their in their
power spectrum and what she saw in this
case was the cancellation proceeded
faster rate and was more effective for
the natural signal than for these
artificial signals so this is not
unexpected but it points to kind of the
conclusion that the reason why this
basis may work so well in this fish is
that it's matched to the structure of
the input so this is maybe kind of an
interesting general lesson that
representations needn't be all purpose
like a delay line but if the
representations are suited to the
particular problem that the system faces
maybe you can do just as well and that's
kind of what we see here the green line
in the model is a case where we deleted
the new be seized from the model when
this provides additional confirmation
that their role in generating these
delayed and diverse responses was
important as we expected ok so our
knowledge of the key ingredients in this
circuit of the granule cell
representations in the learning rule
also provides us with an opportunity to
make some very specific predictions
capacity performing negative images the
capacity for plasticity in this system
so we wanted to pursue this in the last
set of experiments so for these set of
experiments instead of delivering a
natural sensory input to the mg cell we
asked about its capacity to form
negative images under artificial
conditions in which we directly inject
current into the cell to evoke action
potentials lot to the EOD motor command
so this is kind of like asking about the
impulse response of the system and we're
taking into account the capacity of the
system to to generate negative images so
what do we expect to be able to what do
we expect to happen in this situation so
the result of this kind of experiment
where we're voting a postsynaptic spiked
to the motor command the plasticity we
induced is going to depend on two
factors that we've already discussed one
is the learning rule and the other is
the temporal patterns of response and
the granule cells we know both of these
so we should be able to predict what's
going to happen in these kind of
experiments so first for illustration
let's take the case of a delay line so
in this simple experiment what would
happen for a delay line kind of
representation so if we inject current
novogo spike at a short delay after the
motor
command granule cells that are active
just before the spike will be weakened
according to this aunty hebbian spike
timing dependent plasticity rule over
some minutes of pairing these weekend
synapses then will contribute to
hyperpolarization of the membrane
potential of this cell so when we turn
the current injection off we'll see a
dip in the membrane potential this is a
simple reduced form of the negative
image and we can repeat this experiment
now shifting the delay of the current
injection over in time and if the basis
was a delay line if the representations
were uniform in time the learning rule
is the same everywhere in time we would
simply see this dip translate across ok
so this is as a hypothesis from a delay
line what do we expect given a natural
representations in the granule cell so
we observe so these are far from a delay
line we see many more cells active early
after the command that late so we expect
a different pattern and because we know
the learning we can quantitatively
predict what the pattern of change
should be and that's what we did so for
an experiment which we pair with a
current injection at 125 milliseconds if
the granule cells were a delay line we'd
expect to see a temporally specific
depression at a long delay but given the
granule cell responses that we actually
observe we expect quite this different
pattern so a biphasic pattern where we
have an excitation early this is due to
the non-associative potentiation part of
the learning rule acting on the large
number of granule cells that are active
early in the command cycle and then a
societal dude to the smaller number of
cells that are active and long delays
okay so what do we see when we actually
do this experiment so here's the
response before any pairing we inject
spikes who inject current to evoke
spikes at this long delay and when we
look at the change post- pre we see a
pattern of change a negative image in
this cell that's very much like the
negative image that we predict based on
learning rule and uneven pattern
temporal patterns of granule cells that
we actually
so this is some kind of confirmation
that our general understanding of the
learning rule of the granule cell
responses and how they contribute to the
formation of these sensory predictions
in this system is relatively as well so
we could repeat this experiment for a
range of delays the green is the
prediction the black is the change in
the response after pairing and we see
that in all cases this agrees quite well
with the predictions and is not what we
would expect from a delay line so in the
case of this simple temporally specific
negative image we think we have to a
first pass a pretty good idea of
actually how this works at the circuit
level so the animal can predict the
sensory consequences of motor commands
subtract them out so he's more sensitive
to the world so he solves this problem
of reference he solves the problem of
translating a copy a literal copy of a
motor command into a language that can
predict sensory consequences and that's
all done through these fairly simple
mechanisms synaptic plasticity rule in
this case the nature of the plasticity
is critical it is anti hebbian synaptic
plasticity and that's acting on some
kind of suitable representation so
corollary discharge representatives who
have been transformed in the circuitry
of the granular layer this made you know
something about the cerebellum some of
these basic some of these basic
ingredients are very similar to models
of the cerebellum so one question you
might have in a top for a few more
minutes here about this is whether this
very simple forward model so in some
ways you might think this is kind of a
trivial example of a of an internal
model because the this motor act that's
being whose consequences are being
predicted is completely stereotyped so
this is about the most simple motor acts
that you can imagine it's simply an
electrical pulse and what we're
predicting is just a pattern in one
dimension of time so in some sense maybe
one wonders whether these mechanisms
that we've highlighted here would
actually work the contacts to generate
generating internal model for
in order controls can you predict the
sensory consequences of an arm movement
where there's many more dimensions and
what's interesting to us is actually
that in the fish and in ll we have a lot
of evidence that the same system the
same circuitry solves more complex
internal model problems if you will than
just this one that we've talked about so
far I've talked about the temporally
specific negative images because we
understand them the best but we also
know that for the active electrosensory
system of this fish that the fish's own
movements are a big source big source of
self generated noise so remember there's
a lateral receptor scattered over the
skin there's an electric organ in the
tail the active sense is geared toward
detecting perturbations in the fish's
self-generated field due to objects in
the environment so every time the fish's
moves so every possibility assumes
that's a function of bending along and
many joints of his body there'll be a
pattern of electrosensory reference that
the system needs to account for account
for if he is just detect objects in the
environment so it seems like the system
somehow needs to learn the
higher-dimensional more complex mapping
between postures of the fish and the
pattern the spatial and temporal pattern
of electro sensory input at each point
on the skin of the fish okay so can the
fish do this and we think it can so I'll
show you just quickly data from quite a
few years ago where we actually asked
this question directly can the fish
encode information can i ll neurons code
information about objects in the
environment irrespective of the
movements of the animal so in these
experiments we move an object to
behaviorally relevant stimulus an object
next to the base of the fish at the same
time we're moving the tail of the fish
back and forth and in this situation
he's making an electrical work and
discharge so if we before the voltage on
the skin changes both as a function of
the position of the object it's about
here but also the position of the tail
so again this is the problem of
reactants for the fish but now in the
context of his own movements and then if
we look at the responses in the brain
first at the skin then at the level of
the afferents then at the e ll neurons
we see again an interesting
transformation as you'd expect in terms
of the at the level of the current at
the skin you see a
strong dependence of the field both on
the position of the tail so the gradient
colors here also the position of the
object same thing at the level of the
afferents they have no way to
distinguish self from other so they
respond strongly to both but then if we
look up at the level of e ll neurons
they seem to have solved this problem
they're showing variant responses to the
object position and they don't respond
at all to the movements of the fish's
own body to his own posture so it seems
like the system may also solve this
problem so you can just closing here
kind of recast this problem in our same
framework and kind of food for thought
can these kind of simple mechanisms that
we've talked about here if we expand
them a little bit flush them out can
they also account for more complex
internal models and that's something
we're interested in the labs imagine the
sensory input to the system now depends
on joint angles and it's plotting to
hear but there many joint angles so the
reactance is a function of the different
angles of the fish's body that comes in
need to generate some kind of literal
that advantage of that and of course you
can imagine how we're going to do this
in this simple model we have the same
learning rule that we know exists and
then we have some basis of body
representations in the granule cells so
I don't have time to go over all the
evidence but we have actually a lot of
evidence that the main components of
this model are also
rule is established we know that granule
cells in addition to receiving corollary
discharge inputs also received massive
proprioceptive inputs that convey
information about the fishes oh and
position different parts of its body as
tail as Trump his fins they also receive
motor commands related to his movement
so if we electrically stimulate the
brain avoca movement then paralyzed the
fish report from the granule cells we
see motor poor Larry discharge responses
in the granule cells so there seems to
be evidence for this kind of basis of
body position fish and then just a
little bit of s so because the fish
actually made heck advantages in this
domain so here's more sets of
experiments that we did in which we're
now changing the amplitude of an
electrosensory stimulus apply to the
skin of the fish has a function of the
position of the fish's tail so the tail
is either in the middle MC position or
the contras position and now we're
burying the amplitude of a stimulus
smoothly to create these profiles so
this is a manipulation of the sensory
consequences of the fish's own movements
which are applied passively experience
we do this for 10 or 15 minutes now we
turn the stimulus off continue to move
the body of the fish we again see these
quite nice negative images of the
sensory consequences of the fish's own
posture so for us this is some evidence
that these basic ideas of negative
images of simple forward model and this
system could be expanded to more complex
problems in higher dimensions we're very
interested in an understanding how to
bridge is mayor dad was saying how do
you bridge gaps between simple circuit
mechanisms like these and the more
complex internal models that we imagine
we have in our brains that we imagine
the cerebellum perhaps it's generating
how to bridge these levels and so we
think this system offers some potential
for doing this and again for us you know
particular interest is the question of
the cerebellum so the circuitry we study
in the electric fish is very like the
cerebellum in particular this massive
layer of granule cells that provide
plastic inputs converging on a readout
neuron for Kim G cell mg cell here
it's very similar to the circuitry of
the cerebellum probably know about
cerebellum and structure or Allah was
just an implementation of supervised
learning and ll that's very very similar
to the classic Morales models cerebellum
so you really new here there's a lot of
congruence between our ideas of
plasticity and granule cell bases and
yell and the cerebellum so those things
are basically the same on the other hand
there's kind of an interesting
congruence in ideas not what the
cerebellum is actually doing at a more
systems level the idea that the
cerebellum like what we've talked about
for you ll is a predictor of sensory
consequences of motor commands or some
kind of a forward model so these things
have kind of come evolved together and
for us that's quite interesting than to
think you know how to bridge these gaps
how to extend ideas from a ll where it's
quite easy to witness these into these
kind of forward models and see play
these games that we've played in this
fish how to extend this to more to
internal models in the cerebellar
circuitry and think about what what we
either learn or what important pieces
are missing in terms of bridging these
kind of gaps so that's all say thank you